i define a master as someone who has
fully stepped in and owned the full
progress and trajectory of their life
it's alright that you didn't win no it's
not alright if you don't win you need to
win rise and shine it's an espresso time
good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside to you that I want to see
exploded onto the world so let's start
your day off right together grab your
coffee and sip on today's message on
your life over to you Oprah Winfrey my
intention in creating masterclass came
from the understanding that everybody's
story is the same all stories are
connected and there is nothing that
anyone who's living on earth has ever
felt or known or experienced on a soul
level that hasn't been felt or known or
experienced by someone else one of the
most difficult things in life is feeling
that you are the only one you are the
only one who's travelled this path who's
felt this way I had nowhere to go I was
homeless at the time I lost my family
the next thing I know I'm in this car
for three years where I'm struggling
who's experienced such a devastation or
joy or triumph or victory so for me I
define a master as someone who has fully
stepped in and owned the full progress
and trajectory of their life
persistence pays off that's lesson one
but hearing stories told from the mouths
of people who know how to live how to
course-correct how to keep going how to
never quit how to rejoice in the good
times and have faith in the bagged those
people are masters anyone who can do
that is a master and their ability to
share their stories only helps the
trajectory of others who listen you are
here right now because of you your
accomplishments are all because of you
and your failures are all because of you
as well it's time to take ownership for
where you're at you can't blame your
parents anymore you can't blame your
education anymore you can't blame your
country anymore you're an adult and you
have to take responsibility for where
you're at I think as long as you are
blaming somebody else as long as it's
somebody else's fault for you being
where you're at then you never take
action because it's so nice and
convenient and warm feeling to be able
to put the blame on somebody else right
it's your parents fault that you're not
successful right because you didn't get
the education because you're born in the
wrong country that's why and so as long
as you tell yourself that story then
you're gonna stay where you are because
you don't have to do anything anymore
and so what I want to really encourage
you to take dramatic ownership for where
you're at every success that you have
had is because of what you have done you
are here right now because of you
because of the actions that you've taken
and you're not further ahead also
because of you because of the actions
that you were too afraid to take because
the action that you didn't want to take
because of the actions that you blame
somebody else for you look at someone
like Oprah Winfrey it's hard to imagine
someone coming from a worse background
than Oprah Winfrey you know she didn't
know her parents for a good chunk of
time she was sexually abused growing up
she was so poor that her grandmother sew
dresses out of potato sacks right
potatoes come in these big bags and her
grandmother had no money and so she
would take those potato bags and sew
them together make them into a dress for
Oprah and she had to go to school
dressed in potato bags
you can imagine the ridicule that she
face when she went to school look at all
the things that she had to deal with and
what she went on to do becoming one of
the most successful most influential
entrepreneurs women thought leaders in
the world are you gonna tell me that
your situation growing up is worse when
Oprah had to deal with and so if she can
go from there to where she's at now
what's your excuse your excuse are all
the people that you're blaming for you
not accept their responsibility your
excuse are all of those people who are
saying it's your fault it's not my fault
and until you say it's my fault until
you say I'm gonna own my life then
you're gonna stay exactly where you want
to the choice is yours now I've got a
special bonus clip for you but before
getting to that my question of the day
for you is who have you been blaming who
have you been blaming that you're gonna
put that aside now it's no longer their
fault it's yours who have you been
blaming for your lack of success leave
it down in the comments below I'm really
curious to see what you have to say
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of an espresso
and enjoy the bonus
[Music]
my dreams are first everyday then my
wife then my kids I could take care of
my wife and my kids now would you agree
I abandoned this this is the fuel for
Who I am I abandon this dream and then I
end up I can't take care of them and
then I'm gonna tell them what it's
alright that you didn't win no it's not
alright if you don't win you need to win
how many of you need to win more okay if
you don't control your environment folks
somebody else is going to control your
environment you guys have run teams and
run organizations if you do not control
your environment someone else will
control your environment you are being
controlled in your environment right now
CNBC CNN MSNBC the parents the kids the
Twitter the Facebook the YouTube the
Google the snapchats
are your environment your friends in
your relatives your uncle's your aunts
the garbage dump called planet Earth
that you live on is mostly broken people
if you don't control your environment it
starts with me when I was 45 years old
Mike I'm gonna control my environment
I'm gonna take every penny I have all
the energy I have all the resources I
have and I'm gonna improve me if I got
to go broke in the process because I'm
already broke look if you're not
fulfilled in your if you're not reaching
your full potential every day you're
broke right now as a new artist how you
rise and how you come up is kind of
really crucial because in the mean time
because you could be creating your
blueprint at the same time you know your
structure and no one else could be going
up the same way as you so I tend to try
and like not do things differently but
just do it my way you know like I always
have to know what the back of my website
looks like or I always have to know you
know when so-and-so is coming out and
why there isn't posters of my album out
yet on the walls you know I mean I kind
of always I'm involved with everything
even it's for a split second even if
it's just a question I think that's why
I think it's really important that every
eye should be like that and not just
depend on you know the label it's your
project you know she'll baby so you got
to make sure you look at every single
aspect there's nothing that goes past
that these eyes right here like this but
you are very much in control of your
career society it's not an easy thing to
do how did you learn how to do that tell
me about the process of learning how to
be in control well I've always been a
control freak from a very young age and
but I would have credit my management
for that like when I'm like really
really tired and I'm like can you just
decide I can't bothered right now no
saying up to a 5:00 a.m. until you
understand everything and then you can
give me a yes or a No with a good reason
and stuff like that so definitely my
maths good man as well yeah oh no my
management a great light and also like
they want me to make the decisions on
everything small things big things where
vijai mean so that and it's my music and
I'm the artist
so why someone in a boardroom who's
never written a record in their lives
should be making decisions for me no we
are the artists and we should be allowed
to decide
full volume you have the most important
work ever if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple
that would be collect a little beacon
pay believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details